novembre 1975 enterrement du général
espagnol franco francisco franco amendé
entre dans sa dernière demeure
la basilique souterraine
il a voulu qu'il a fait creuser
il a fait construire
une basilique aujourd'hui au coeur des
polémiques l'édifice situé à 50
kilomètres de madrid a été construit
sous les ordres de franco par vingt
mille prisonniers politiques
un mausolée qui se voulait symbole de
l'unité nationale mais qui dès le départ
devient le mausolée du fascisme espagnol
pour preuve le fondateur du parti
fasciste y est aussi enterrer le général
franck où sera inhumé aux côtés
d'antonio primo de ribera fondateur de
la phalange
dès lors chaque 20 novembre date
anniversaire de la mort de franco ce
mausolée devient un lieu de
rassemblement pour les nostalgiques du
fascisme exemple en 1985 général franco
le ch a dominé pendant plus cher charles
né à beaucoup de tranquillité dpd gaieté
en 2005 à faire un grand coup a conduit
l'espagne en avant on nous a donné du
travail et nous avons bien vécu
on doit penser à lui comme une grande
figure de l'espagne et le salut fasciste
était même appris aux enfants qui n'ont
connu ni la guerre civile ni le régime
dictatorial respect à mon général franco
et elle est à sauver l'espagne de
communisme moi je suis raciste des
rassemblements embarrassant pour
l'espagne qui votent une loi en 2007
interdisant l'apologie du régime
fasciste conséquence déboulonnage des
statuts à la gloire de franco et
interdiction de se rassembler sur la
tombe du défunt dictateur
c'est d'ici que depuis 32 ans ces
derniers fidèles lui rendent hommage
mais c'est l'ultime pèlerinage à la
vallée des los caidos une loi dite de
mémoire historique interdit désormais
tout rassemblement politique sur ce
monument mais malgré cette loi le
mausolée reste
un lieu de culte embarrassant
alors le gouvernement de pedro sanchez a
autorisé l'exhumation des restes de
l'ancien dictateur
mais où va être exhumé sa dépouille à
madrid dans un caveau familial
oubli acceptation l'espagne n'a pas
fermé toutes les plaies de son passé
[Musique]